germany's busiest airport is at a
standstill thousands of passengers have
been stranded in frankford waiting for
hours for security checks union reps
apologize for the delay we had nice to
the regulations that we didn't expect so
many passengers to be brought here we
thought they'd be transferred to rail
travel instead the question is simply
this was this taken seriously on what we
couldn't reckon with there being so many
passengers here today and us it's even
harder so Philip azhagiya off he isn't
transfers were unaffected by the strike
but anyone who had to go through
security controls was in for a long wait
more than 80 flights were cancelled and
the airport managing company Fraport
told travelers to stay home I'm afraid
that I'm i lost my flyer and after I
don't know what like what I we do
to get my home day for the weekend we
are on the right channel and now ya know
it's incredible incredible the very
Union pulled employees of a private
security company off the job and says
most of them heeded the call it wants
wages of 16 euros per hour for its
members employers are only offering
between 10 and 13 euros